michael graham is a Boston Herald
columnist and host of Michael in the
morning podcaster ricochet comm and he
joins us tonight to assess this cascade
of failures and the self-righteousness
that have followed this seems like to me
Michael the biggest case of deflection
on record the government officials
rather than stopping and saying you know
what we screwed up and we're gonna find
out why are saying America it's your
fault you know when you listen to you
recounting all those events obviously
the culprit Tucker is the NRA
if only the NRA were destroyed then we
would solve all these problems I love
this argument that we are not competent
enough to own guns to protect ourselves
because we're too stupid we'll shoot our
eye out whatever so we have to rely on
government so we say okay how about the
government well actually they're out in
the parking lot hiding waiting till the
shooting is over so can I have a gun no
no that just proves that guns don't work
it's it's a your heads I win tails you
lose argument from people who want to
restrict gun rights
it really something's going on here
though because I still have respect for
and affection for law enforcement I know
a million of them great people protect
us here at Fox grateful to them but here
you have apparently according to reports
tonight four separate armed cops or
deputies sheriff's deputies refusing to
go in you can't tell me that all four of
them were just cowards I mean there must
be is there some policy in place of each
of a cross-section of Americans just
pick four at least one of them would
have gone in none of these guys did what
is that about that's a very good point
because a normal person could not stand
there with a gun and listen to kids get
killed without running in the door if
you so I wrote a piece for the
Federalists today going back and looking
at other incidents where the cops stayed
outside people forget the orlando
massacre which was the worst shooting in
modern America until Las Vegas the cop
actually shot had a gun fire a gun
exchange with the killer the killer gets
in the cop stays outside then he waits
and this watch shows up and they stand
outside three hours while murder is
going on inside in Newtown according to
the judicial review afterwards a cop
stood outside for four or five minutes
listening to the gunfire and did not go
in the building and part there so there
are two branches here one is cowardice I
think the president is right to make
that point but the other is training
that Department still haven't figured
out how they're gonna deal with these
issues Columbine was supposed to be
turning point we know people waited
outside at Columbine because we'd never
seen a Columbine it's kind of like 9/11
you can't blame people for not
understanding 9/11 we've never seen it
well this is the post 9/11 post
Columbine moment just as people on a put
airplane will never sit and wait you
know for the hijackers to take the plane
anywhere police should not sit and wait
for people to die inside the building
and the argument I got today and I heard
from a lot of police officers today is
you don't stand Michael if we go in
they'll be danger wait there's a guy
with a gun in there they're dead people
I think the danger parts already covered
and then the second and this is truly
disturbing I'm with you
my uncle is retired LAPD he was honored
for heroism twice his brother was a
deputy I have law enforcement my family
the vast majority want to do the right
thing yeah it's a number of police
officers who have told me point-blank my
number one job is to go home safe at
night to my family though and they point
to a Supreme Court case that says that
police do not have a duty to protect you
and I think to myself if that's really
how you view the world if you're really
your number one job is to go home safe
at night then you need to find a mall
that needs a security guard and and do
that for living the reason we honor cops
is that cops do that amazing business
they see danger and they see an innocent
person and themselves and they say I'm
going to choose to get between the
innocent person and the bad guy that's
why we honor cops we might have inner
cops because they're the best policy in
they sit outside a car waiting for the
SWAT team if they don't want to protect
that's fine but don't prevent us from
protecting ourselves I mean let's just
be honest about what we're dealing with
Jack Mike Michael thank you for that I
was really insightful thank you